okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have some
special guests on the channel
hi gabby you know me
what's up kamel aka jelly aka gels
travis charles aka king charles
the third fourth fifth whatever you want
to say
and before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos if you
want to get my attention on the stream
send a super chat and you we will the
panel will answer your questions
cool boom
i will answer
i will
record
no no
so the reason i actually invited these
guys on the lives is they have their own
podcast
well i do have my own podcast i started
with my friends in um
covet times it's called life is a
shamble podcast i haven't done a podcast
in a while but this wednesday i'm uh i'm
gonna bring you back i've been busy
playing basketball
doing school
being doing a lot but i'm gonna bring it
back and you can find it on spotify or
apple and then we have a youtube one as
well that we posted so go check it out
and do you want to tell them where they
can find you too
um travis charles you can find me on
facebook instagram
twitter
at king charles underscore 30 on twitter
i uh just regular travis i have an
instagram man i can't remember it right
now because this guy's a little scramble
you know
but a regular travis shows on instagram
and on youtube as well um i have uh me
and camilla are gonna obviously come
together and do some big things and on
his podcast and spread the word
yes we shall
gabby do you want to plug your stuff too
um i don't want y'all to find me i'm a
ghost so
i'm just here
okay
[Music]
so the topic today is do you guys
believe that soul mates are real yes or
no
[Music]
sorry
no he can go first the way you said the
way he said it's like you you were ready
well no i do i
because i know my beliefs and like i
definitely think soul mates are real but
i don't think you have just one soul i
think that there's twin flames you have
soul mates but i don't think i think in
life you evolve so much that you have
multiple soul mates and it depends on
that period of time in your life and
where you're at and soul connections are
real like i think like i've had soul
mates that are friends i know that for
sure are we still met [ __ ] we're so
mean
you you know like soul connections are
real but that doesn't mean that it's
just one person
or just one sex or one gender that's my
take
interesting interesting interesting
well
i do agree with her in the sense that i
don't think you have one just like i
don't think that
you'll fall in love just with just one
person over your lifetime you'll fall in
love with someone multiple people
you have multiple soul mates
when in terms of soul mates i believe
like
sometimes it's more sexual
it could be
intellectual like your soulmate can be
connected between like various factors
and all
so
i do believe in soul mates different
factors for that though
hey listen i agree with both parties
um
as a man
i'm i'm coming from most people are are
going to go back to their belief beliefs
in terms of how they were brought up
um me being a christian man i definitely
believe in soul mates and that you have
multiple
partners at different points in your
life and when things fail god will
arrive something new that being said
wait we have a question
so you're christian
how do you believe in multiple soul
mates
at different points in your life how
difficult your life so okay so as you
grow as a human being you can meet
somebody that you're not ready for and
god put that person in your life
and he put the person in your life to
teach you a lesson for what's to come
and that person could be at 18 to 20
years old
from 22 to 25 that person could be from
30 to 33 and when you get married or
whatever time is and this outside gave
you a little chronological timeline
from
35
to the rest of your life until you die
so that being said um it's just at
different points in your life
like the people that spoke before me
said and um
i just believe that
uh when the time is right
uh obviously you
learn from your past relationships
you're supposed to look yourself in the
mirror and say where did i go wrong
what can i do better and what can i do
to you know put myself in a position to
succeed in terms of you know hopefully
being mindful of until then pass away
see it's interesting because i don't
believe in soul mates at all
okay but can i ask okay yeah i think
that's your podcast like you have told
me before that you're very religious so
how does that relate to your religious
beliefs that you don't believe in like
soulmates well i think religion
it comes down to choices so if i started
let's say i started and only fans
tomorrow would that change the type of
husband i get no no i think it does i
think your choices affect like the type
of person you have that's the right i
feel like the right person for you could
look past that [ __ ] and
sorry stuff
the right man it may and when i say the
right man i'm not saying that it's like
a man like a man could be one way with
you and a different way with another
girl that's right for them so the right
man for you would be able to look past
that and that's all i'll say so if i
started porn tomorrow i can't say that
on youtube corn
tomorrow
you think the right man should just look
look past that if he's your the right
person for you yes 100 he should be no i
i really think it's your choice but what
about in life if you start doing corn
yeah but what if that is like
you have lived a life and this is a way
for you to make money and provide for
yourself or
vice versa you've never known someone's
story right you know what i'm saying and
there are people that just
do it you know everyone's different but
like
you know if
if that's what you did to provide or
just to survive or you went through
certain things in your life that have
made you be hypersexual
and whatnot well i mean the thing is i
know i've lived like i you know i had a
very sheltered like childhood so i'm in
a situation where like you know i'm not
gonna judge someone for what they've had
to do when i like haven't had to like
struggle like that you know
but
at the same time like it's gonna be your
future husband starts off as a complete
stranger so how is he supposed to not
judge you when he doesn't know you
well i think that also depends on like
for example if you're somebody who
would never
resort to that
you're probably going to look for a
partner who wouldn't be with someone who
would respond to that right but that's
why i think it comes back to like the
choices you make or the as that's the
type of partner you end up with yeah
because i think like you want someone
with the same values as you
so but does doing like
sex work
per se
there are values and morals like
personally that's not something i would
do right
personally
but
when i look at other people that
do that kind of stuff i don't say well
what are your morals and what are your
values i have more more so think of
what brought you to this point in your
life to where you felt that you had to
well there's a difference like there's
some people who just do it because they
don't give up
sorry yeah but you know there's also
people that do a lot of girls do it
because they feel like they don't have
another option
okay i'll ask you guys would you guys
date a girl would you marry a girl
mother of your children
who has done corn
i want you to go first come on audrey
please listen
i agree with um
both of what you're saying to be honest
but i follow more so
what pearl's saying we all have choices
like you can be from
a poor background and still be
successful you could choose
a life that's
makes you a bad quote-unquote bad
citizen
or you can
choose bad citizens that's a strong word
very bad
listen you could be a criminal you could
you could but what is okay criminal and
sex work is super different yes
think about it you don't have to be a
sex worker you there's so many things
but but exactly what you think about sex
work think about it your body if you
think about it your body we're talking
about we're talking about
soul ties right now
giving yourself to multiple people
here and there you don't think you're
getting soul ties from that but but in
what way are you talking about
physically or just over like
it's different with
physically and then emotionally as well
you can give yourself to someone
physically but you never gave them to
emotion it's quite different in my
opinion okay also let's talk about the
fact that this whole world of of only
fans and whatnot was
the consumers are men
it's not women it's men and women have
been over sexualized throughout their
life and
have been you know we structuralize
ourselves uh i'm sorry
that's not true because no it's not no
it's not because we grow up in a society
that that tells you
like men will want you if you are a
certain type of way right so like
okay like sex work women wouldn't do
that if men weren't like that that's
them capitalizing on the entire both
sides but at least but we have a backup
plan like if a man is broke he's broken
homeless like
you don't see them like coming also
the whole men this world is run by
privileged white men women didn't
couldn't even vote until what i don't
even know
why don't we bring it i and i agree
but what is that what awesome because
it's getting too political
your followers are going to be here what
does that mean
yes
we're talking
about because it's getting too political
so i'ma shut up now you're welcome
i'm gonna shut up
you sure yeah no shut up
don't worry i'll pick you back up i feel
like okay what were you a bit of a
cop-out to be honest
i feel like it's a bit of combo like you
still have to make your choices by
yourself you don't have to do you don't
have to do certain things that you don't
want to do so even though
quote unquote men
sexualized woman this and that there's a
lot of smart women who know this
and use it to their advantages to get in
spaces
where they can gain resources resources
to boss upon these men
you don't have to no that's fact that's
bad yeah how you're saying it's like
you're saying that they have no choice
no i'm saying that let's not judge women
that are brought to that point that's
what i'm saying no one brings you to a
point
you have a choice everything in life is
a choice
okay
and i'm talking for the women who feel
like they haven't had a choice in that
situation so you're talking about
everything life is a choice but there
are genuinely women who throughout their
life have not been shown how to value
themselves other than their sexuality
right their body that is their commodity
so if that is their way of surviving in
a very harsh world for a lot of people a
lot of women specifically and that's how
they provide then who's to judge
that's and
again
let me shut up but it's not it's not
judging to say i wouldn't marry that
person that's your own thing yeah that's
what i'm saying like i think men have a
right to be selective in who they date
and marry yeah and so i don't think that
like we're entitled to their
understanding
you know what i mean like i think
that
like there's a difference between saying
i wouldn't date that person and you know
saying you're a terrible person because
that's what you had to do i feel like
there's also a difference though like
for example
i have someone in my family who started
doing sex work
only fans because she wanted some extra
money but she didn't need it she had a
place to live that's i feel like that is
a different situation my opinion on that
is completely different rather than
someone who literally is just trying to
survive right i just think you can't
[Music]
okay wait pause for a second um
yes i was about to say um thank you for
the super chat in the comments um pearl
you got the facts and we back you up
she's talking crazy sorry because your
whole following is okay
anti-feminism pro mail
youtube
i said a lot of followers are also kind
of racist so canadian
that's why friends followers hate me why
because you stick up for what's right
what's right to me
and that's what i'm like
it's fine yeah my opinions are very
strong that's why i shouldn't be on this
type of platform they love
and that's the thing like only fans is a
choice men can't like if they're five
five what are they supposed to do yes
fires doing a lot of short men are rude
because they have short man syndrome
okay
that's just that's true
i don't think a sharp man can handle you
no i know that they can because i've had
one before that has one there's only one
one what but it's only the one that's
the only one i've allowed
she said so you like
like big tall strong men
do you see me i'm a big [ __ ] like yes
yes
not suitable for children
she want the strength
oh my god
okay okay
okay second question do you guys believe
in soul ties yes or no
define the soul ties for god
a soul mate is like the one person
you're supposed to end up with that's
like right for you a soul tie is like
when you sleep with someone you're like
connected to them in some way
because it's kind of interesting because
birth control just changed the whole
dating game so much
because people used to get married so
much younger like like now the average
age of first marriage in the uk is 31 in
the for women and like 32 for men and in
the u.s it's like 28 for women 29 for
men where before they used to get
married like younger i feel like it's
also because women are more independent
now and have more financial capability
to take care of themselves for sure
for sure but that's why that's what i'm
saying like before you know people would
wait till they were married because they
get married at like 17 to like 20 right
but now people are almost 30.
so they have like a whole decade of
sleeping around go ahead just ask a
question respectfully yeah
i forgot there was a show on netflix
last year around uh
christmas time
and basically it was showing that
when
i forgot the show it was basically the
uk england back in like the
1500s and basically when women were
married they said to the husband and
when other women knew that
that man was married and other men knew
that a woman was married they
backed off
okay yeah
yeah so that's also another topic and
what's making and i don't mean to get
controversial what's making a people
cheat or what's making people saying
listen you're married
i want you more now i had a conversation
with my barber
wednesday and he was telling me
that basically he just got married and
he was telling me flat out at once
he was basically telling me that um
that
his
when he went to his church a whole bunch
of women pulled up to him when he when
they see the
his uh ring finger was covered
and that a woman invited him to his ho
to her house on valentine's day
well it's because um
it's like it's well it's if there's a
butt he didn't go
he's a nigerian
no he didn't he's a nigerian christian
he's a good man he's a good man he's a
good man
innocence i love you you cut my hair you
do a good job he said please don't [ __ ]
up my [ __ ] fade
why are you trying to blow up my spot
i'm a leo that's why
[Music]
i'm in the mic no i think they said it's
better guys let us know in the chat if
it's better well you understand that
like for men that's um that's there's a
biological reason why women like married
men is it's a sign of pre-selection so
before um like in the old days when we
would like have to find a guy to take
care of us if he showed that he took
care of other women
um then it's like it's pre-selection so
women want a man that other women want
yeah i'm trying to be getting taken care
of
how about that how about i
be the stay-at-home dad
i take care of the kids some come on we
cook right
i'll be at home with the kids
her followers dragged me it's fine
they love you though they always they
always request you back
yes because they love to drag me because
i'm not a [ __ ] privileged white male
i love this energy though
i love this energy she she's given she's
let her audience know i am what i am
this is who i am
all i have to say is my audience would
be extremely different than what this
audience is that's all i have to say
no but if i did it would not be these
people watching me
having your podcast will be very angry
you sound like you have a lot of anger
in you let me see anger towards
privileged white men yes
i do
everyone else is cool just her followers
are all privileged white men but you
realize i'm a privileged white girl yeah
i do so you like me
i do like you
but that's but that's why we don't talk
about politics bro i feel like you're
reasonable though you understand you
understand your privilege you understand
other people's struggles
and i understand well i think you have
to go through certain things to actually
understand it you know what i mean but
yeah i am empathetic i would say
but i'm also very opinionated so that's
why i have this show pearl's a stats
girl she is a numbers girl oh you one of
them nba gm's like oh they shoot more
threes because no worries or no i don't
watch sports
okay
okay
okay
specifically a basketball player so when
you say analytics i'm like oh man down
maury threes threes
threes and two you see why they don't
like that
no i'm not saying that
so um next question do you guys know
what hypergamy is
no talk to me do you know what do you
know what hypergamy is
oh when a woman should date a man who
makes more money yeah
sort of
it's more like women want a guy that
they can like look up to in some way so
like for example an example where i'm
hypergamous is i wouldn't date a guy
shorter than me like so i want someone
taller than me right so that's hypergamy
um another example is making more money
um usually like a girl wants a guy
that's like better looking than her
typically is what like i'm describing is
hypergamy is that what you guys have
seen um in dating would you say that
girls are always on to the like the next
best thing i want to come out to go
usually i should go after come outside i
might come out respectfully to go first
i feel like women
and society
they place values on certain things
money height etc etc which i don't
believe it's the right things but like
at the end of the day you know what you
want and what you want is what you want
so if you want a man that can provide
for you first of all
i'm never gonna be like okay
you're doing too much let's say you're a
woman
you want a certain type of lifestyle
you're accustomed to a certain lifestyle
you say hey i'm not gonna date a man
that doesn't pay my bills this and that
hey
i know
i can't afford that so i'm not going to
talk to you but somebody will
pay for it somebody will take care of
you so that's fine as long as you know
you should do it
but don't be the type of person that
says oh i'm independent i'm this and
that but you need someone to provide for
you that's when i go okay
you're doing you do too much you're
contradicting yourself now right i'm all
about
if you say something say this is what i
like that's what i need
stick to it but don't place your values
don't understand say i'm independent i'm
on this and that no you're not
go ahead okay so
this is why i said we want to get along
two leos
but like okay so what if i as a woman
and like
i'm independent and i'm gonna make my
own but that's and that's fine until i
have children and i want to be there and
raise my children and i want to be with
a man that can provide for the family
until i can start working again until
they're of a certain age
to where they can be in school and like
you know i don't want a nanny or
like there's
let's and that's a whole nother thing
child care and
quality child care
i don't want somebody that i don't
really trust and know and child care is
very expensive it's not affordable to
raise my children and so what if i don't
want to marry a man
that
maybe i make more money than him at
first but if i need to stop working
because a children needs their mother
more than their father and that's just
facts
they really do not months in yeah
yeah like when the baby is young it
needs the mother to be there to feed
them i mean and i'm talking more
personally breastfeeding like that's
what i'm thinking naturally
trust me
not to community people i'm talking like
more like thinking of a motherly like
you're you have to feed your child every
couple hours
yeah like
would your opinion change when i'm
talking from that standpoint listen
when you're talking
to a man at that stage first of all it
depends on your age say you're in your
mid-20s you are not thinking about can
this guy take care of my kids isn't that
you're thinking about oh
that's not driving me
she's not trailing that
i'll tell you right now it's not in her
mind she's talking she's like you're
talking to two women and you're saying
it's not there's first of all my mom my
mom talked in my mind my
don't have mom unless you can provide
for you yeah to others that's just how
my mom taught me because she's beautiful
she's a single mother she's raised
three
boys by herself my mom always tells us
like you're gonna have kids don't have
kids this and that you're gonna have
kids make sure you can provide for
yourself and two others that's why
i'm not really doing those things man
i'm dreaming and i'm jimmying up clearly
your mother raised you right i'm not
swimming without a life jacket
no love no love
that's just out but
so you don't think girls
think about that honestly they do like
women
we do
woman you take them on a date and first
of all they're already thinking about
the three kids they're gonna have what
they're naming them
i've done these scenarios in my head
with girls that i really liked so i
already know they do that often they do
that way more than us but i must say i
don't believe that when you're talking
to a woman at that point they're like oh
this is not no
what they like at that point if they're
that type of girl quote unquote like the
clout they want someone that can provide
for them
they already know
what type of environment they're going
to be in they already know where to find
these men it's just that
they don't want to they're not looking
for no intellectual man no hurry
i hear you this is how it is women that
are just looking for like a step up like
a like a free ticket and that's fine
yeah and that's fine if that's your
lifestyle that's your lifestyle because
at the end of the day they
is more so onto the man they already
know what type of woman that they're
dealing with
so
they're the women are playing the field
and
it's just it's on to the man to decide
okay am i gonna take this girl seriously
i might not and they already know like
if that girl is not in your lane you
already know it's gonna cost you yep my
dollars is not talking like that yeah
i'm not giving a deal there's certain
girls
there i already know what's up yeah you
already know we're talking about yeah
and that's fine that's you can be
attractive you can do your thing but
like any day i can't take you seriously
in that sense
but you're not wrong for thinking oh
i don't trust this man
if we i get pregnant
to you know take care of me and a child
it's all and women women do get the
short end of the stick and i do believe
that
you guys i do believe that you guys
should have those options in the sense
that
as soon as you get pregnant your career
goals everything takes a break so in
that sense you guys should have all the
options to control like what you want
and i'm always for that agreed because
what do you mean what do you mean all
the options like what do you mean by
that exactly what she's saying child
support and stuff like that who am i
going to talk to what kind of guy am i
going to talk to just because i know
that if i get pregnant today my job can
replace me to go on leave man doesn't
have to deal with the labor all that
all the effects of well
no i'm sorry
[ __ ] you
ouch
moderate no moderators
we ban anyone in the chat that insults
people on their looks that's not cool so
um i'm [ __ ] cute as [ __ ]
no they just that's how it's because i
don't like
white men so it's definitely a white guy
though oh yeah no 100 percent
secure white man he messaged you on
twitter no well he's not okay well no no
he's a troll it's simon levine like yeah
yeah it's not the actual no no no okay
okay on twitter
no one who is happy in their life
okay
i wasn't gonna read the comments i'm
gonna give you 20k okay how much is he
dropping two dollars okay okay um
wait guys quiet for a second so the next
super chat i got could you date an
atheist or someone who doesn't believe
in soul mates or someone who's
completely different set of beliefs from
alex schmidt
um thank you for the donation
okay so i would like to go first on this
one okay because i i went to channel the
next the last topic i couldn't but me
personally i couldn't at all okay uh
somebody that's the atheist me
my family being born from
[Music]
my friends from the caribbean i was born
in new york a lot of korean people of
toronto new york london all throughout
the uk
um i've had certain experiences in my
life life and death wise where basically
i'm like yeah god is real kind of thing
and
i just couldn't do it eve even if my
mother father
and other people took me to church and
said tries to believe in god i would
but that being said but the certain
things that i experienced in my life
especially from the pandemic to now
i couldn't do it um so she would have to
be christian
or catholic or whatever
uh more times more time than not more
dude more time than not
he only date christian girls
i got a question because you talk to me
beliefs are very important how you're
raised i was i was raised christian but
yeah what if you fell in love with a
girl let's say
she's buddhist or she's muslim but you
love the girl how do you do that
and in terms of how do you raise your
kids like this is something we talked
about okay my friends like how do you do
that because
i know personally like i've had family
members i've cut off relationships
because everything was going good but
just the religion was just so key that
they're like yo i can't raise i can't be
going one way and my husband's this way
yes how do you move doing that knowing
that all right so and the bible says
what you got you need to be equally
yolked equally yo easily
that being said you said buddhist and
muslim well i might give you a little
quick fact that and a lot of people
don't read the bible enough like
christians don't read the bible enough
i'm gonna be brutally honest i started
doing it more when i got um when i came
overseas because i had a lot more time
on my hands and i said i want to grow
more as a man
and god said um a man is the head of the
household but the woman is the neck and
the woman just as important as the man
so
this head that we all have
wouldn't be standing without the neck
so i'm gonna let you i'm let everybody
know that now that being said
um
so i i did my research
uh
not necessarily just online but within
the bible and
uh abraham they called the abrahamic
faith judaism christianity in islam
so islam was birthed from ishmael
ishmael
was hagar hagar was the wife was the
concubine of um
of abraham
and for the simple fact that
um sarah abraham's initial wife couldn't
have children she had children right
and when she had her first child
ishmael
and
eventually
where are you going with that
[Music]
directly like i just want to know if you
date a christian girl i forgot what the
question was
essentially is the father of islam under
abraham and jacob his second son
is the father of christianity or father
christianity even though he's not jesus
christ
god in the flesh that being said i feel
like certain um
certain
um i'm i'm awful for and love but for
travis charles personally obviously you
want you want to marry somebody with the
same faith yeah values that you have
yeah
i think most people look at that first
first and foremost you don't think god
would understand
if you have if
let's say you're going to heaven
well
you believe in god you're doing
everything you're praying this and that
your wife is something else quote
unquote you should be going to heaven no
she might not so would that be a problem
then if you're if we're we're talking in
those terms
did that be a problem until the
abrahamic faith
christianity or all religion that's what
i'm saying i'm talking i'm just talking
about you in general you love this woman
to death
she believes in something because she
was raised like that yes and you believe
in something because you're raised like
that yes
how are you gonna feel because you can't
just you guys just break something just
like that
you can't you don't think god will
understand if god so if god is you know
so forgiving so understand you don't
think he should would understand that
but this is what i'm saying well if
you're are you christian i'm a christian
yeah that's but i'm saying like the a
pillar of the christian belief is you
can't like get into heaven unless you're
baptized
i believe in jesus christ yeah yeah so
that's
i've been baptized i've been baptized
still
here's the problem with only dating in
your church okay it's actually not
really a problem for men because there's
more men in the church
but
oh sorry more women more women more
women sorry sorry there's but for women
they they would always say in my church
like back home that like you could only
date a guy in the church but i'm like
there's three girls for every one guy
that's conservative
what yeah yeah so then all these girls i
think just end up alone because they're
waiting for a guy in the church that's
never going to come
so in my opinion the church kind of
keeps women single and i don't think i
think god is conducive to like families
like he wants families to start yes and
i don't know i think there's something
about like biblical institutions
that have been running men out of them
the last like 50 years what do you mean
like like why are all these men they're
men used to be really involved in the
church yes and but they're not anymore
so something about these institutions
are running men out
talk to me come on
no they can't hear you come to mind i'm
gonna take my i have to pee you take my
mic
if you want see what i'm saying okay i'm
gonna repeat
there's
okay one is because men might be seen as
i don't think i can say this on youtube
they say
you can't say it on youtube it flags it
okay
okay yeah involved with the young
children
yeah
yeah and then the second is the rise of
independent women
in the church
honestly what i'm thinking about when we
talk about church institutions is like
one thing person this is just a side
note
i think a lot of people
need to
focus more
on their relationship with god yes than
a church because i had
growing up i had a mother who put all
her time in the church this and that
this and that
and then there will be like shady things
happening in the church is going on
so why
but at the end of the day
basically it's all about your
relationship with god yes
so all the other stuff don't really
matter so when we put all our time
in uh doing this and that for the pastor
for
i don't think i think it's a waste of
time not a waste of time but like you
can put your efforts in better things
well every institution is going to get
corrupted at some point like there's no
there's not a perfect institution
but but i think but i think that you got
to ask yourself the question does that
mean we just do away with them and don't
use them at all no no i'm not yeah i'm
not saying that but
know
know where your focus should be
know what your time should go into yes
basically in my in my opinion like
there's certain things that the church
do
that you should
feed into prayer helping out each other
i remember i was at prep school
in north carolina i was good i was in i
don't even need the prep school but i
was at a prep school
and every week
the pastor the pastor's out here getting
um he said oh yeah
offerings for this offering for that
he's like yeah the prep school here
uh everyone would do an offer for the
floor we never saw the floor got done up
nothing oh my god and i was putting i
was putting in 20 us dollars i didn't
have no money at the time but the floors
were bad
and the pro the the pastor gave me a a
sermon and it hit me i was like i say
move me i'm like yeah i'm up i'm gonna
tap my car for this 20. it moved me and
then after everyone's like yo what are
you doing don't do it i'm like why
you're like bro this guy does this every
year he's never fixed the floor jeez and
he has like
six cars in his garage um so those type
of things when i say right when i say
focus on your relationship with god and
not yeah not believing yeah
yeah
that's yeah those are the points that i
mean you know yeah not to interrupt you
but that man ultimately has an answer to
god for that he has to answer to god for
manipulating god's people or the sheep
or or the the or the bride of the church
for his own personal benefit he has to
answer to god for that and that and this
and that's why i agree with you
you got i was saying the same i write a
lot i love to write that's one of my uh
greatest gifts
creativity is my number one number two
of the right
and
one of the things that i write um
sometimes daily is that you have to form
your own personal relationship with god
because pastors and certain people can
manipulate who you are
and what they want from you
so um outside of
religion what else are your deal
breakers like so you have to have the
same religion as a girl
more times than not
abraham abrahamic faith okay but
more times like i will probably lean
towards uh christian and you're his
friend so does he does he only date does
he only date the christian girls i don't
know what he dates i just met chav i'm
glad i'm fortunate to meet this oh you
just met him i thought you guys knew
each other well i noticed in august is a
great guy stand up guy
mind me i can't speak on him but me
personally my deal breakers will be
people
that really don't have no driving
motivation like i said i was raised by a
single mother so i get out the mud
so i don't want anybody that's lazy i
want no one that doesn't have no
ambition like i don't care
where you are in your life at this stage
but like
when you're speaking when you're
whenever we're speaking
you have to tell like if we're talking
you say what do you want to do in the
future
you have to tell me oh my plans to do
this and that are you have an idea if
you're just sitting around okay so what
else what else what else
what else yeah
looks
like
it's the remember this
is
people that i won't talk to but hey i'm
all about connections we are
heterosexual men who are attracted to
creatures
would you guys date a girl that's
overweight
no i have a six-pack
jesus christ god please forgive me
no no no let's be real here let's be
real here let's be real here let's be
real i'm an athlete
i want somebody that has a quote-unquote
active lifestyle
and i probably attract people in that
section so
no dis but i don't think overweight
people single mom
single mom better response a better
response hey hello a better response
would have been
that's just not my preference
it's not about practice
i have a personal training certificate
i'll put her to work we'll get him
twisted
tonight
chase i'm sorry i have to recuperate
because you did you date a girl as a kid
though
yeah this means
my my oldest brother my oldest brother
he is dating a woman well it's her
fiance now they get married
in july
and
when i came to london for the first time
i was born in england i came back to
london for the first time he's dating a
lady and she had a child already but the
way they had the relationship
her child and then my my brother it was
just so like seamless you know like it's
just as natural having a child doesn't
really affect me in general like if i
really love you i love your child at the
same time yes so that's not really a
deal breaker in my opinion
if you have someone that's toxic
in a relationship then it might be a
factor where it goes let's say your your
ex partner with them you don't have a
good relationship with it mm-hmm it
might be a little techy it might be
it might ruin or hinder things
especially
you having a child in general mm-hmm
doesn't really affect how i feel about
you if i
if i love you and i feel like i can take
you seriously then obviously i'll be in
the workforce i wouldn't i wouldn't you
wouldn't no no
i love kids i just
i think
like
don't rate it no i mean look at i love i
really do like i love kids like i get
really excited when i see babies because
they're like all chubby and stuff you
know
but um i don't know i just feel like
there's something special about like
having your first child like with
somebody that is someone that already
yeah yeah like together and i just don't
like it's like a bond you're supposed to
have with like one person i think what
you don't think
you can love their you can know you
don't think you can love their child and
then have your own child with them i
think i think i absolutely could but i
would just rather not like i would just
rather date someone without kids
earlier did you not say you could have
multiple soul partners or did i make
that i was soul ties so yeah
oh yeah we forgot to even soul mate
did you say that yes no i i don't
believe in soul mates i think we choose
who we date
and i think you're who you date and
attract is based on your choices like if
i gained 100 pounds i think my partner
would be very different then all right
so
so if you if you dated somebody and you
thought you loved them and then had a
child
would they would that then eliminate you
from
dating anyone else because
you've got a special tie with that
person
if i wait i had the kid
yes you had the child well i think if i
had a kid that would eliminate like a
lot of guys probably wouldn't want to
date me because i had the kid
but there's still guys that will date
yeah they would women who have children
there's good guys out there
no i know but i don't think it makes
someone a bad guy because they don't
want to date someone with kids
oh that's what he said that's what he
said
those were things
no i think
what would you say
those words didn't come up okay okay
are archer thinks different
even though we do agree on certain
things or some things this is all right
this is the uh the actual youtube thing
the admin oh wait the bot is getting on
to you because you keep on sniffing
well the reason why i keep on sniffing
is because i have a condition called
adam noise hey who's lemonade that's my
moderator yeah that's the moderator
sorry
problem
no
okay okay okay guys don't respond to the
comp please don't don't
it's kind of a waste of time to just
like go back and forth with trolls
okay so the reality is i don't have a
drug problem i do have adenoids which is
a gland by
a hole in your throat that i didn't know
until i had covered the third time and
survived
that it it clogs up and swells that hole
which lisa knows and sometimes you know
i get a runny nose this is why you don't
charge this is why you do not dry now
lemonade lemonade babe don't you feel
like a piece of
beep
what came out of my ass
wait so would you date a girl with a kid
personally
no okay i won't because i have a son
okay
so
it's just a bit weird to introduce my
son to somebody else
and then
another child too it just makes things
are
very complicated
something that i'm just not ready for
personally
what were you saying about soul ties you
had a question earlier
i can't remember what it was um somebody
in the comments
because i'm in the comments you guys see
me commenting and everything yeah
if you if you remember what i was trying
to say then
hit me hit up the comments
and i'll definitely read it because my
phone's underneath the table so yeah
do you guys believe in soul ties
like basically every person you like
sleep with you have like a connection
with them sort of for the rest of your
life uh i would like to chime in first
really quick and just make it get
straight to the point yes yeah i believe
one person
out of that two-person party if it's a
two-person thing somebody would get more
attached to the other person
and it would bring that tie i believe
obviously sex created by god for the
reason of procreation and within
marriage
for
intimacy and pleasure
that being said
uh yes i do believe it's all ties
stop stop stop
i'm sorry i'm one for the comments
i'm in the comments if you guys want to
say anything i'll clap back
you just have to ignore the like
commenter yeah it gives it a bit of a
job no the reason why i don't like to
ignore the comments because
the over overwhelming majority of
comments are great comments
but like with everything in life
whenever something negative happens
it stands out
no but like it gives them attention
yeah so i'm saying like when you give
them attention they do it more
apologies
so for those who think i do coke i don't
but if you if you're a man you want to
fight me you know where to find me i'm a
southampton so15 won't give up the last
these hands work and they work very well
trust and believe
all right and with that being said
my short cameo is over guys i hope you
like me
my name is oj you see me in the comments
the juice man
it's okay we only have like 10 minutes
left so we're almost done
we're almost done well one more
conversation
[Music]
i'm not broke oh you want to see him
all right
it just got critical ladies and
gentlemen
do you guys think
because i don't know
i feel like naturally like people used
to get married
so young
and now like the dating game is so
different
i agree with you but this happened
because
of social media oh yeah
and people are more accessible now so
before game used to go to high school
all you knew was the people in your high
school then you went to college you met
a lot more people
then all you knew was the people in your
college and your high school
and if you wanted to
date anybody it would be those people
now social medias come here
you can be somebody in taiwan
meet somebody in australia
they may tickle your fancy
tickle your face that's a good one
i need a bed to stay here
i would like i would like to chime in on
that real quick
so
i like to pick people's brain
i after i think when i first came back
from my injury with the calf injury
um
i met that i was talking to a couple
i took i was took this older couple
irish couple
married
married 57 years together for 60.
and they would give me basically this is
a positive vibe and i'm saying
why are you still with him i asked the
woman i like to pick a woman's brain
first ask that woman why is she with him
she was giving me the whole spell i'm
gonna try to sum it up but basically she
was telling me you guys i feel sorry for
she was saying specifically she feel
sorry for the women in this day and age
right because
men especially men of a higher status
have more options that being said
um she's not saying certain women don't
have our options because we had talked
about that as well
but it was one of those things where
basically
she was saying people don't work through
things anymore
apart you guys have a disagreement
people break up and like oj said they
can quickly find somebody on social
media well do you want do you want to
know an interesting stat
if you ask 85
you know what they want to do no
if you ask 80 of women what they want in
a guy they list 20 of men
so the reason that women hate men is
because we're all sleeping with the same
ones i agree
yeah
some argue it's an even smaller
percentage than that
like for for example how tall are you
guys
you're what i am a star boy yeah okay
stop stop we're not gonna argue with the
comments like respectfully
i've said this so many times
no no i've said this
okay okay okay okay okay well this is
this is my podcast and we're not gonna
do that here okay
um
but
um i forgot what i was even talking
about
oh okay okay so six five and six so the
reason like i'm tall right
so i'm i'm six foot right so if i want
to date a guy that's taller than me
that's six foot and up right that's only
15 of guys oh [ __ ] and so yeah and so if
you go taller than that it's like yeah
yeah we're really treasured then
this is why this is why this is where
the basketball teams run through school
yeah like do you think that's what
you've seen like it's a small percentage
of guys that get all the girls is that
what you've seen definitely definitely
yeah
and do you feel like women think that
they're hotter than they are typically
i'm 10
women search for power money and status
boom that's true
a check mark well look at simon levine
has a girlfriend that's a model
the tinder so he still has a girl
because he's famous i saw something on
snapchat yeah no was it snapchat it was
he's on tick tock
tick tock it was it was something it was
some social media
it was one uh
when girls somebody said to a girl
put
the male version of yourself on like a
field or something
if you don't like yourself you need to
lower your standards
yeah
yeah
and a lot of people were angry in the
comments
because well it's because that small
percentage of guys will still sleep with
like the guy that's a nine or a 10 will
still sleep with a girl that's a four
better useless
there's a reason behind it i think we
value it as much there's a no is this it
there's a bigger reason why it's a
biological reason you guys are
programmed to spread your seed where
women we have more of a cost
you literally are like biologically yes
you are yes you are men have a higher
sex drive than women i agree
[Music]
the testosterone that we have is higher
than women that being said we also
spread naturally
if a woman what wanted to have a child
she could only have one child of the
year yeah exactly yeah yeah you could
literally go around the world if there
were no stds
asterisks by them
we can say listen we can have literally
like 500 kids in the world yeah oh god i
am not spreading anything i'm not saying
i'm not saying all men choose to do that
i'm saying like like everyone we have
nature right go ahead
she's right if you listen like if you
listen to what she's saying she's not
saying you as individuals i know agree
she's saying men as a collector the the
oj listen listen listen
i could go out and throw around
and
impregnate as many women as i want to
the vet
the vet oh gee the vet is speaking
women could get pregnant one time and
they'd done at the game for nine months
game
based on biology she's right
then it comes down to individual
churches
i love it some people aren't just out
here slinging
why did we say this
[Music]
well in the same way like women we're
programmed to get the highest like
status guy that we can so we're trying
to
work
yeah like it depends each girl has a
different like thing like for a super
religious girl like it might be the guy
that's high up in the church right for a
girl that cares about instagram thought
like whatever status she cares about
but you know it doesn't mean that every
single girl is going to leave her
husband the second you know someone
better than him is interested idris elba
chris brown
you know the usual no
whatever woman that woman drool over you
know what i mean yeah
yeah it's just like our general nature
is you know i agree
but
social media i don't think social media
has changed the game as much as birth
control has because when you added birth
control to the game that took away the
consequence like before women could just
sleep with whoever but like you run a
really big risk of getting pregnant but
you bring in birth control that takes
the consequence of a child and so if you
take away the consequences like they're
gonna do it more
if you take away the consequences
people will do the actions
like i i bet you
if people wouldn't go to jail for murder
yeah more people would deal with it
no no that's okay
i'm saying what like i could like you
know
the whole movie the movie yeah
is based on that yeah they take away the
consequences for 24 hours and people out
here doing crazy stuff yeah
doing them doing a madness yeah but um
where were we well we were talking about
i was saying how birth control changed
the game yes birth control did change
the game
it made people it made the consequences
less well and i think it kind of
inflated girls egos too because now they
have access to
like these guys that they wouldn't sleep
with before and then social media on top
of that yeah and everybody else
accessible yeah so what like tinder
what's that what's another one
hinge
what's another one instagram yeah
instagram facebook twitter all of them
all of them things there google yeah
google
yeah you could google anybody's name and
find them well and like
like have you have you had an nba player
slide in your dms
oh
yeah she said that she she said that
earlier
let's let's let's leave with that yes no
but i'm saying like i have it i feel
like i'm like a normal like like person
pretty privileged yeah but like i don't
even i don't even feel like like
thank you but you know i mean like
there's a million
look at this trauma
i'm just giving away what credit is good
thank you but
you do understand what i'm saying like i
feel like i'm like a normal person and
that's happened to me but like that's
happened to a million girls where
they're just like average people and
these famous guys will like slide in
your dms
want to know why
they want easy sounds consequences don't
be taken away it's not necessarily see
you say easy sex so i was watching um
like i'm not dumb enough no no no no no
no the consequences have been taken away
everybody's accessible yeah yeah that's
true i agree with that
before i came to meet kamel and these
guys i was watching
i was watching vlad tv and basically
michael john white was saying that a lot
of
a lot of top-notch women
who are who are on a higher level you
don't know what they have to deal with
so he said uh a lot of celebrity men
like him who are on top of the game like
a-list celebrities they like to deal
with regular women
because there's not a consequence of the
ego they have to deal with with
top-notch women
some that he said some men feel like he
said some men want to deal with
i don't know like janet jackson or
beyonce or at least yeah that's a a-list
celebrity who dominates her craft some
men want to deal with that and some men
don't so i don't know it it just up
beauty is now the beholder mm-hmm
you see somebody
sick of your fancy
i don't think men are as picky as women
to be honest
men are not as picky as women oh geez
spill the beans come on no men swipe
right on like 50
of women let me explain to you what i
mean
oh i get it like there's a difference
between i get it that there's a
difference between like sexual attention
and relationship attention is that okay
go ahead go ahead because one is the
hunter and the other is the hunted
[Music]
so so true guys
please please tell me
all right all right
nowadays girls are a bit more forward so
girls will approach a guy if they like
him what do you say
some
that's what i'm saying it does depend on
the girl but some guys might be
intimidated by that because they're not
ready for that but
because we were talking about gender
roles earlier and
feminism
hey don't do this
archer come on son don't be defense
are supposed to go out and get girls
wine and dine them
and if masculine men roll if they like
what's going on
then they'd be like yeah
you could take me out but then that
leads to
guys getting saved in girl's phone book
says
free meal oh yeah
yeah
i was i wasn't prepared for that taxi it
also depends
oh yeah definitely this is this isn't
this isn't it
what gabby said was this depends on the
type of girl the type of girl you choose
and i agree
not all the girls are out here trying to
get free meals
and a free taxi to wherever she needs to
go
not all guys out here trying to sling
out toy story
if you were here if you were here
earlier you know what toy story means
[Music]
who lord have mercy god please who was
like yes partner in toy story i can't
remember
okay i'm 70 years old following what's
going on okay okay
like i said i'm just trying to keep it
honest all right it is what it is it's a
vicious game it's a vicious cycle
right because it's it's like everyone's
kind of afraid like men are afraid of
being used for their resources and women
are afraid of being used for their
bodies bingo oh my god
also thank you to the perfect guy for
donating two dollars if i don't exist
how do i send this super chat
wait let me move the drinks out of the
way
[Music]
what time do you guys have to go
i don't know we have to go live okay 15
minutes ago okay we should have said
something oh we were really enjoying
this because
you're okay you guys can come back
followers out here chad i'm in the
comments with them too yeah
you guys want to tell them where they
can find you
yeah
yeah stream labs do you want to tell
them where they can find you me everyone
like you got instagram youtube you could
definitely find me in the street and i'm
joking
you'll find me on instagram n4 smart
area london
north london orlando it's my name
first initial my last name
same name for twitter
facebook you see me in the comments
find my name find me on facebook
oh no podcast for me
i'm
no i don't do drugs so
just eliminate that from your mind but
uh you can find me on pretty much any
platform just regular travis charles i
have different names and aliases because
i don't know a different social media is
deleted and hacked and all kinds of
criticism know who you are chris i know
who you are chris
no but on twitter's it's king charles
underscore 30 or just having travis
charles they'll probably find me
instagram is i think king t charles
underscore 94. shout out to that dude
smith
i'm in the comments
but
or just regular travel shows on
instagram the lights hitting you nice
out there
thank you i appreciate that you see a
black man elevating another black man i
appreciate that that's what i do but
facebook just regular travis charles and
uh youtube uh
me and kamal are gonna partner on the
podcast and talk about interesting
topics like this and like other people
also encourage you like we're just it's
not going to just talk we want to
encourage other people god gave me a
message i want to spread it that being
said
uh i think youtube is just regular
travis charles as well
but
yeah
[Music]
are all gels mellow j-e-l-l-z-e
[Music]
m-e-l-o gels mellow
and that's it if you want to watch my
podcast
i have a couple episodes maybe about 11
12.
it's called life is a shamble because
for some reason my life is always in a
shambles so it's like a play on a joke
it's like a joke now life is a shamble
something happens to me shamble i came
to the uk
two
[Music]
anyways ladies go ahead plug yourselves
in mess it ladies okay real quick shout
out
lord have
[Laughter]
do you want to plug anything no okay
okay thank you she got so many haters
okay thank you for watching everybody
thank you